l'athlétic club salle et inscrire son
nom au palmarès de la course du souvenir
pour la première fois de son histoire
on sait qu'il peut prendre le départ à
7h30 à savant du fort à saint pierre
après la cité artisanale au quartier
trois ponts courant vont se détacher du
groupe pierre bureau du golden star tony
moulai du club péléen et data graines de
la cs qui remet le témoin en première
position
2e pierre bureau troisième tony moulai
quatrième philippe de maso et gérald
gladone 5e sur la deuxième étape
gaëtan fait taux de la csg goro du club
péléen blessé au mollet seront dépassés
par kevin rudd stander du golden star
qui remet notamment en première position
près de la crèche du morne-rouge
deuxième gheit en fait tout s'est
d'ailleurs à ce point au mont rouge que
les six équipes féminines ont pris le
départ depuis 7h le golden star et la
mairie sport qui font la course en tête
à fond marie reine l'athlète de la
mairie sportive commence à se détacher
dylan manière a repris la tête de course
pour la cs je lis et frati est relié à
la deuxième place
à la mythique étape du tunnel entre le
méchant de la csf 1er aurélien raphaël
du club péléen est deuxième la mairie
avec jordan thire est troisième après
une belle course de georges mélies la
mairie sportive avec mathias gauche est
en tête sur la 7e étape
la cs reproche de commodes et mac os
sundar on s'en va pas faire la première
victoire du club salisien dans le temps
de 2 heures 3 minutes et 10 secondes
un peu avant l'athlète féminine de la
mairie sportivo roselyne ml franchit
également vainqueur la ligne d'arrivée
[Musique]
je suis contente pour l'équipe parce que
vraiment baissé déjà un travail d'équipé
et moi j'ai juste fait l'arrivée donc
mes coéquipières elles ont fait tout le
boulot et il faut dire qu'on était
avantagé par le temps était clément avec
nous et on était préparé ton ça de toute
façon chacun
né à fond sur chaque relais et au final
bas c'est ça qui nous permet de
l'emporter aujourd'hui c'est tout
c'était quand même serré la mairie ce
parti nous a donné du fil à retordre
aujourd'hui la victoire de la csa chez
les hommes devant la mairie sportive et
le club playoffs pendant sa nouveau la
course du souvenir